depuis qu'il a acheté son épicerie il y
a quinze empreintes canon n'a jamais vu
d'augmentation prix aussi élevé que
celles des derniers mois définitivement
les produits laitiers sont les produits
qui ont le plus augmenté est ce que
c'est parce que c'est la dernière que ça
nous a frappés mais à des augmentations
qui oscille entre 6 et 15 % c'est un
produit qu'on vendait la semaine passée
4 et 9 et je vends cette semaine cat et
49 c 40 cents d'augmentation en quelques
jours
le prix de la viande aussi à augmenter
au point où les clients se tournent de
plus en plus vers d'autres produits ici
vous avez un boeuf du québec un bug de
qualité où est le faux filet est à 47 et
38 du kilo alors que le poulet
biologiques de charlevoix est à moins de
15 $ du kilo
les fruits et légumes c'est relativement
stable on a vu des augmentations mais
c'est beaucoup plus lié encore au climat
à la température est plutôt que
réellement une augmentation vieille
drastique entendre la semaine prochaine
ça s'apprend 10% puis ça descendra plus
quand on regarde l'iceberg à 99 cents
pièces sont magnifiques en plus
d'augmenter
personne qui dit qu'elle peut pas manger
une salade cette semaine
est un problème là les augmentations
prix proposé par les anciens ou les
fournisseurs ne sont pas obligatoires
mais il serait plutôt difficile pour les
épiceries de ne pas les appliquer une
épicerie très bien géré et va générer en
fin d'année des marges maximum de 2 %
sur le chiffre d'affaires les épiciers
doivent en plus composer avec la pénurie
de main d'oeuvre moi je viens de mettre
250 milles dans des caisses automatiques
parce que j'avais pas de monde et même
si les employés sont moins nombreux sur
le plancher la masse salariale elle ne
diminue pas les hausses de salaires
aussi entre 5 et 20% selon les
catégories d'emploi en magasin versus ya
trois ans cette pénurie de main-d'oeuvre
frappe aussi les fournisseurs et les
amène à offrir - drabek a l'habitude
actuellement cette compagnie la
recherche des employés doit les payer
plus cher et ne fournit ces commandes
alors c'est certain qu'ils se lancent
pas dans des spéciaux les magasins
continuent quand même d'offrir des
soldes afin d'attirer les clients par
exemple le sucre 2 kg lantic qui est un
spécial cette semaine que je vends donc
en spéciale à une 99mo moncoutant à
l'achat est de 2,50 mais on a ces
produits là qui font en sorte qu'on va
espérer que la dame qui va venir
chercher le sucre lantic belle elle va
acheter du lait elle va acheter du
chocolat pour faire un gâteau et chez
derek jeter
je crois pas que les compagnies pourront
réimposer de nouvelles augmentations
prix il y a une il ya une limite à ce
que le client peut
absorber ce que l'économie on peut peut
absorber aussi un donc moi je crois que
le pire est passé on croise les doigts
quant aux habitudes de consommation il
faudra encore attendre quelques mois
avec l'ouverture des restaurants il le
retour des rassemblements intérieur pour
voir à quel point elles ont changé
durablement ici marie claude morin
radio-canada mon rire
dominic lapointe et économiste principal
à valeurs mobilières banque laurentienne
bonsoir monsieur lapointe bonsoir alors
on va je vous posais des questions de
base sur l'inflation pour faire le tour
de la question puis la question
fondamentale en fait combien de temps
cette inflation là va perdurer et et va
augmenter comme ça est-ce que sur
l'inflation qu'on croyait qu'elle était
passagère ou du bout de lac au vide ou
est ce que c'est une inflation avec
laquelle il faudra s'habituer à vivre
ses programmes à la question que tout le
monde aimerait avoir une réponse
définitive mais je vous dirais le
consensus parmi les économistes en ce
moment c'est qu'on s'approche du pic de
l'inflation
on s'attendait avant la venue du variant
au micro que ce soit atteint environ
mois de décembre donc légèrement votre
5% canada on a des délais dans un peu
les effets de distorsion qui sont
importants que la pandémie cause
continue de causer et ça ça fait que les
façons continuent de monter il ya aussi
des événements géopolitiques notamment
vous avez mentionné la russie sa course
de l'inflation dans l'énergie qui cause
un délai dans le retournement à peu à la
normale de l'inflation donc on s'attend
à ce que ça passe environ 5% jusqu'à
légèrement votre 3% à la fin de l'année
ok donc vous dites le consensus chez les
économistes
on a déjà vu ça à peu près tous les
économies se tromper mais le consensus
actuellement si on regarde le tableau 1
la courbe ces crises ça va redescendre
janvier février mars
pas nécessairement en fait auprès
s'attendent même à ce que ça continue a
augmenté au mois de février en raison du
pétrole février un des produits laitiers
on sait que ça va augmenter beaucoup au
début du mois mais c'est plus haut médoc
ont ré ouvre l'économie regret à divers
postes au canada partout dans le monde
sont nos potes d'autres vagues beaucoup
de distorsions liées à la consommation
je donne un exemple on consomme beaucoup
plus de biens de consommation qui est du
service ça ça pourrait mettre alléger
les pressions sur les chaînes de
production ce qui ferait en sorte qu'il
y au moins déflation dans les biens
notamment pendant la nuit bon ok mais on
serait au chemin vous serez pas loin du
chemin au loin bon qu'est ce qui
explique la disparité on va voir le
tableau 5 entre les différents secteurs
lier le pétrole monte façon vertigineuse
les aliments un peu moins qu est ce qui
explique la disparité mes impôts les
sens il faut remonter à ou ce qu'on en
était en 2020 au moment où la pandémie a
éclaté en avril 2020 on se rappelle il
ya eu une journée où le prix du baril de
pétrole s'échangeait pour des valeurs
négatives le ce qui n'était jamais vu on
est passé s'arrêtent pas seulement 0 on
ne remonte à cinquante plus on n'est pas
loin de 100 dollars donc c'est une
inflation qui pressent que vous avez
montré l'état 30 2% c'est normal puisque
le baril pétrole partie de presque rien
pour les autres aliments la nourriture
dans le reportage auparavant parlé d'
effets des changements climatiques mais
encore une fois la pandémie aux du coût
du transport hausse du coût de la main
d'oeuvre ça se reflète beaucoup pour les
prêts à la consommation puis le logement
c'est un homme est vraiment important
prix des maisons c'était déjà un
problème avant la pandémie ça s'est
accentuée pendant la pandémie dont je
reviens au pétrole une seconde
vous dit le brut effectivement il ya été
négatif reçue pendant une journée ou
deux il est remonté presque à ça est-ce
qu'on s'attend compte tenu de
l'incertitude pour l'ukraine compte tenu
de la production internationale qui a
baissé un peu plus que le prix continuer
à monter jusqu'où ça peut monter à la
pompe par exemple ici ouais je vous
dirais que peut-être que monsieur admire
poutine une réponse plus claire à cet
élément là parce que en ce moment les
marchés sont vraiment pas certain de
ckoi des intentions d'harris en écran
c'est que la russie en ce moment produit
environ autant de baril de pétrole sont
les quotas de l'opep que l'arabie
saoudite donc c'est un producteur très
importants sont amenés des sanctions
pour les exportations russes ou non la
russie pourrait décider de simplement
resterait une volontairement ses
exportations de pétrole ou de gaz
naturel le baril pourrait monter
facilement aux 200 $ 100 110 115 pour le
brent si c'est paul que ya une partie de
la hausse des prix qu'on a vu en 81 95
dollars le baril qui pourrait
redescendre bon j'ai parlé de
l'immobilier je fais une parenthèse
immobilière là on est avec la loi
fondamentale de l'offre et la demande il
ya trop d'offres ça vient trop de
demandes qui est passé d' offres on ne
construit pas assez de logements de
maisons ce qui fait que les prix vont
continuer à monter
used et ça c'est un facteur qu'on voyait
beaucoup
2017 2018 avant la dernière hausse de
taux mais le problème aussi c'est que en
seront construits en sont à des niveaux
presque record au canada en termes de
mises en chantier donc on essaie de
construire plus on a un peu limité par
contre la demande c'est qu'elle a
explosé avec la pandémie ce qu'on a vu
c'est que beaucoup de gens décident de
vouloir une maison ou un condo un espace
pour habiter plus large parce qu'on
travaille à domicile c'est logique et en
même temps très peu de failles est ou de
stress financier les gouvernements
donner des transferts aux ménages assez
généreux pas beaucoup de critères de
qualification et c'était pour les aider
à passer à travers la crise mais le
résultat c'est qu'une partie de ceux qui
programment en syrie s'est retourné vers
l'immobilier salle a augmenté aussi la
bulle immobilière
bon alors parlant de bulle immobilière
on a dit la banque du canada aux etats
unis aussi on va augmenter le taux
directeurs je le rappelle on va voir un
tableau kita
quittant un quart pour ça est ce que
vous vous croyez que ce sera le frein
bon est-ce que ça va arriver en avril ou
pas ça sera le frein qui va accélérer la
descente de l'inflation ça va faire une
partie du travail je vous dirais puis on
va commencer probablement ou en mars
vous savez des hausses de taux qui vont
être graduelle parlant 25 points de base
pendant quelques réunions puis ensuite
on va regarder la situation points vip
par la situation financière
mais par contre les problèmes avec la
pandémie là je vous ai parlé la
distorsion de la consommation
malheureusement c'est pas en haussant
les taux qu'on peut tout régler on parle
de la nourriture l'effet des changements
climatiques ou de sécheresse qu'on a eue
l'an dernier ou dans les prairies ça
peut encore arriver cet été malgré qu'on
hausse les taux même chose pour
l'énergie qu'on hausse les taux
directeurs au canada ou aux états unis
si on a malheureusement une guerre en
ukraine difficile de voir le baril de
pétrole retombé dans ces conditions
l'offre doit vraiment être assez radical
dans notre hausse de taux pour freiner
la consommation au point où les gens
veulent - m d'essence dans la voiture
exactement ce que c'est les taux
d'intérêt auront rien à voir avec ça ils
vont freiner la consommation mais ne
peut pas freiner le prix du brut qui
peut monter de façon important avant de
vous laisser en théorie économique en
est en pénurie de main d'oeuvre les
salaires augmentent or le jeu vous
montrer le tableau 4 l'inflation on le
dit depuis le début de l'émission 5,1
pour ça les salaires 2,4 pour ça les
salaires ne suivent pas pourquoi en plus
on est en pénurie de main d'oeuvre pour
que les salaires ne montent en plus vite
wall e 6 e misterp je voudrais qu'il ya
pas de réponse à ces scènes parmi les
économistes parce que si on remarque aux
états unis où on a le même type de
pénurie de main d'oeuvre dans les
secteurs de distribution
restauration les stars sont beaucoup
plus élevés puis je pense qu au canada
dont les messieurs vous avez montré
c'est l'économie agrégé l'on regarde par
secteur dans le reportage auparavant il
parlait d' entre 5 et 20% d'augmentation
de salaire donc c'est un peu plus élevé
que ce qu'on voit dans le 2,4 pour cent
et une chose qu'on mesure pas bien
nécessairement au canada scellé qui
changent d'emploi donc aux états unis
convaincre les gens qui changent dans le
plan on parle d'une croissance et
salades 3 jusqu'à environ 5% donc je
vous dirais pendant ça va augmenter plus
rapidement à mesure qu'on débute l'année
beaucoup de gens négocient leur salaire
y ont des bonus à la fin de l'année mais
sait pas exactement pourquoi c'est pas
plus élevé en ce moment oui parce qu'il
ya un mystère pascal en théorie selon
livre ça devra augmenter plus vite en
pénurie de main d'oeuvre
dominic lapointe économies sont va se
reparler principale ou valeurs
mobilières banque laurentienne merci
nous avons parlé mais aussi bonne soirée
au revoir